RUSSIA, TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE, TO SHORE UP
ITS MILITARY POWER.
IT IS TESTING NEW WEAPONS, IN
THE ARCTIC, IN AREAS WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN QUITE A BIT OF
ICE MELT.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING
THERE COULD HAVE, IN FACT,
MAJOR IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
UNITED STATES, AND OTHER
WESTERN ALLIES.
NATIONAL SECURITY EDITOR,
NATHAN WALSH, IN LONDON, WITH
THE EXCLUSIVE REPORTING.
EXPERTS HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT
THIS FOR, AT LEAST, A DECADE
NOW.
A LOT OF WHAT THEY FEARED,
RUSSIA SEEMS TO BE IMPLEMENTING
RIGHT NOW.
>> CERTAINLY.
THE ICE WAS MELTING
SIGNIFICANTLY FASTER THAN MANY
SCIENTISTS, DIPLOMATS, OUR
MILITARY EXPERTS ACTUALLY
TALKED.
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA, BUT HERE, THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING SIGNIFICANT TO
MILITARY MANEUVERS, HEIGHTENING
IN THE LAST MONTH OR SO, WITH
THE TEST, AND COMPLETION OF
TESTS, IN THE MONTHS AHEAD.
THESE NEW SUPER WEAPONS, LONG
ADVERTISED BY THE KREMLIN HEAD,
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, VLADIMIR
PUTIN, BUT THOUGHT BY U.S.
OFFICIALS TO, SIMPLY, BE TOO
TERRIFYING TO EVER BE POSSIBLE.
THERE ARE SIGNS, THEY ARE
MOVING TO FRUITION, AND THIS
ENABLES RUSSIA STRONGER HOLD ON,
WHAT IS CALLED, THE NORTHERN
SEA ROUTE.
POTENTIALLY, A ROUTE FROM ASIA,
TO EUROPE, HALF THE LENGTH,
ALMOST, OF THAT OF THE SUEZ
CANAL.
REMEMBER THAT TROUBLE RECENTLY?
YET AGAIN, ANOTHER FACT,
INCREASING COMPETITION FOR
CONTROL ON THIS ICE FREE SEA
LANE.
>> IS THE NEW FOOD TO YOU,
EXPANDING FOR THE WRONG
REASONS.
WITH PUSHING NEIGHBORS, RUSHING
IN.
RUSSIA IS SEEING THE ARCTIC ICE
MELT FAST, FILLING THE GAP WITH
THE MILITARY BUILDUP, SOME OF
IT, UNALASKA'S DOORSTEP, NOT
SEEN SINCE THE COLD WAR.
HE IS A NEW GENERATION OF SUPER
WEAPONS, LIKE 120 MILE AN HOUR
NUCLEAR PROPELLED STEALTH
TORPEDO, DESIGNED, SO RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS TO SNEAK PAST U.S.
COASTAL DEFENSES, AND DETONATE
A WARHEAD, CAUSING A
RADIOACTIVE TSUNAMI TO HIT THE
EAST COAST WITH CONTAMINATED
WATER.
EXPERTS TELL CNN, THE WEAPON IS,
QUOTE, QUITE REAL.
IT WILL BE TESTED IN THE SUMMER
NEAR NORWAY, WHOSE INTELLIGENCE
HAD SAID, IT'S NOT ONLY THE
ECOLOGICAL DAMAGE THAT COULD BE
BAD.
>> IT IS IN THE TESTING PHASE,
IT'S A STRATEGIC SYSTEM, AND IT
IS AIMED AT TARGETS.
THEN, IT HAS THE INFLUENCE, FAR
BEYOND THE REGION, WHICH THEY
TESTED CURRENTLY.
>> SOME SAID RUSSIAN PRESIDENT,
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WAS FANTASIZING
WHEN HE REVEALED THIS, AND
OTHER NEW WEAPONS, LIKE THE
HYPERSONIC MISSILE IN 2018.
BUT CONTINUING DEVELOPMENT
HAWAII IS VERY REAL.
>> RUSSIA IS PROJECTING AN
IMAGE.
MAKING NEW TECHNOLOGY, AND IS
ALSO, DESTABILIZING THE
BALANCE.
>> WE ARE NOW STARTING TO
DEVELOP THOSE CAPABILITIES THAT
COULD REACH THE UNITED, AND ITS
NATO ALLIES.
>> THAT IS NOT ALL RUSSIA IS UP
TO.
CNN OBTAINED SATELLITE IMAGES,
SHOWING THE PERSISTENT BUILDUP
OF RUSSIAN BASES, ALONG ITS
NORTHERN COASTLINE.
PART OF WHAT U.S. STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS CALLED, A
MILITARY CHALLENGE.
CLOSE TO ALASKA, 2 NEW RADAR
STATIONS, WITH A QUICK REACTION
ALERT FOR US SO BOMBERS, AND
JETS.
WEST, A THIN STRIP OF LAND IS
SEEN, OVER 7 YEARS, SLOW GROWTH
OF A LARGER STRIP.
AND, IN THE NORTHERNMOST POINT
IS ANOTHER BASE, SPRINGING UP
SINCE 2015.
ONE OF SEVERAL IN THE ARCTIC,
DECORATED IN THE COLORS OF THE
RUSSIAN FLAG.
THE NEARBY AIRFIELD ARE BOTH
HOME TO MAKE 31 JETS, RECENT
ARRIVALS.
ON THE COAL PENINSULA, OVER THE
LAST 4 YEARS, EXPERTS BELIEVE A
STORAGE FACILITY HAS BEEN
SLOWLY BUILT UP WITH THE
POSEIDON TORPEDO.
>> RUSSIA HAD ITS EYE ON BEING
THE ARCTIC POWER FOR YEARS, IT
IS OBVIOUS TO MAKE THAT HAVE
TO.
YES, IT'S THEIR COASTLINE, BUT
U.S. OFFICIALS EXPRESSED
CONCERNS THAT THIS BUILDUP IS
NOT JUST ABOUT PROTECTING, IT
IS ALSO ABOUT PROJECTING POWER,
ACROSS THE ICE, EVEN TOWARDS
THE NORTH POLE.
>> THERE ARE NEW RESOURCES TO
EXPLOIT, BUT, YES, RUSSIA
RELATIONS VIDEO IN JANUARY.
THE FIRST TIME, I COULDN'T GET
THROUGH THE EAST IN THE QUICK
WINTER, TO SELL THE TRADER TO
ALONG ITS COAST.
>> IT'S TERRIBLE FOR YOU TO BE
CUTTING AS TIDIES FROM ASIA TO
LINK TO KNEECAPS AROUND A
LITTLE BIT.
NEARLY AND ONE HALF.
U.S. OFFICIALS VOICED CONCERN
TO CNN, RUSSIA IS ALREADY
DEMANDING SHIPS USE PERMISSION
TO GET ACCESS.
IN RESPONSE, THEY SAID THEY
SENT BE ONE BOMBERS TO FLY OUT
OF, AND MARINES TO TRAIN, IN
NORWAY.
WHO GETS THEIR FIRST MAKES THE
RULES, THEY SAY.
THE RUSH FOR A PLACE THAT
NOBODY SHOULD WANT TO BE
CONQUERABLE.
>> WE ASKED THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTRY, AND RUSSIAN EXPERTS
FOR COMMENT ON THIS, AND
RECEIVED NO RESPONSE.
BUT, IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT RUSSIAN PRESIDENT,
VLADIMIR PUTIN, PUBLISHED TWICE,
AS POINTED OUT, THEIR INTEREST
IN THE ARCTIC ARE PURELY
ECONOMIC, AND PEACEFUL.
WELL YOU DO SEE THE SIGNIFICANT
MILITARY BUILDUP, RUSSIA, OF
COURSE, WOULD ARGUE THAT THIS
COASTLINE IS EXACTLY WHAT IT
WANTS.
THE BROADER ISSUE HERE IS THAT
RUSH, FOR MILITARY RESOURCES IN
THE NORTH, IS BEING MATCHED BY
OTHER ARCTIC NEIGHBORS, THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS A FEAR, I THINK,
POSSIBLY, THE PACE IN WHICH
THIS IS OCCURRING, WITH
UNPREDICTABLE THINGS LIKE THE
POSEIDON TORPEDO.
A TERRIFYING NOTION THAT COULD,
FRANKLY, LEAD TO MISCALCULATION,
AND COULD LEAD TO, SIMPLY, AN
ESCALATION THERE THAT NO ONE
NEEDS.
THE IMPORTANT THING TO REALIZE,
FRANKLY, IS THIS PART OF THE
WORLD IS AN ACCESSIBLE, BLEAK,
DESOLATE, FOR MILLENNIA.
IT IS NOW SUDDENLY A PLACE
WHERE THEY NEED TO CALCULATE
WHERE THE MILITARILY NEED TO DO,